When you play the game of Thrones you win will you die
Instrumental
Hand clapping
Explosion
There's only one war of the masses and it is here
Hey everybody its charlie you guys all probably saw
HBO's release date trailer for Game of Thrones there's a couple Easter eggs
in here I'll explain what's going on they're pulling a
Marvel for everybody that watched the infinity war trailer last year they're kind of doing the same thing where they're trying to
Mislead you a little bit so I'll explain some of the Easter eggs but george RR martin
also
did an interview talking about winds of winter so we got a whole bunch of new stuff to talk about there's a new round of
That fire and blood book giveaway all you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
And leave a comment on the video i'll name a new winner at the end of this
First big thing about the trailer if you guys haven't noticed HBO the past couple of weeks
Every week has done this big marketing blitz so early theory they're building up towards an actual trailer reveal
They're just trying to get everybody hyped up heading into the holidays they kind of did the same thing last year with a couple
Marathons but it wasn't quite as big as what they're doing right now and that's because the season as we know is premiering in April?
Much earlier that it was premiering last year so they're not waiting quite as long to start promoting it thankfully
Meaning we get new Game of Thrones material faster but I think most of us were a little
confused with the slogan they were using to promote this trailer for the throne because at this point in the story
Most of the main characters don't give a crap about the Iron Throne really this is like Circe's slogan
She's the last person that's holding out like I will not give up this power
but start to finish these are the clips that they put in the trailer you have Jon Snow at the Battle of the bastards
Daenerys at Illyrio's house in season 1 getting ready to get married to Khal Drogo Cersei about to do her walk of shame
Then as the camera focuses on the red keep the quote-unquote Iron Throne they give her that voice over dialogue
When you play the game of Thrones you win or you die then you start to see a pattern
Emerge in the way that they cut these clips together so you see characters losing their lives
attempting to win the game of Thrones
Quote-unquote but the problem with this is is that like Ned Stark for instance like you see the clip of him getting beheaded by Joffrey
He was not?
playing the game of Thrones like he did not care at all he didn't even want to go to King's Landing
He only
did it because he was commanded by his friend and his King Robert Baratheon
So you're starting to see that the trailer was cut together in a very misleading
Fashion like most of these characters didn't really care about the Iron Throne when they
Were doing these things Daenerys with her dragons burning Pyat pree in the house of the undying
Jamie on the field of fire battle last season then Jamie pushing bran out of the tower window during season 1
Sansa greeting the returned bran in Winterfell last season tyrion being led to his trial
Joffrey getting married to Margaery at the purple wedding ned stark's betrayal by Littlefinger in season 1
Littlefinger being executed by Sansa and Arya last season some of the clips do play into the idea of when you play the game of
Thrones you win or you die
Littlefinger definitely was one of the characters that played the game of Thrones they highlight some of the major
betrayals the red wedding sir Jorah Jon Snow confronting Theon for his sacking of Winterfell back in season 2 the Queen of thorns
Poisoning Joffrey during the purple wedding they highlight some of the major
alliances the wildlings joining forces with the Nights Watch during hardhome Jon Snow's northern alliance to fight the Bolton's the Karstarks in the umbers
weirdly enough they highlight some of the risks people took Jaime and Cersei --zz long-running
Relationship that's another good example of something that doesn't really fit with the for the throne
Hashtag, because the reason for them being in that relationship
doesn't really have anything to do with their play for the Iron Throne it would be them splitting apart like that would be a
Sacrifice that they make for the throne and they didn't do that Jaime only left at the end in his leaving had nothing to do
with him wanting the Iron Throne
they highlight some of the
Sacrifices people made most of you realized that Tommen throwing himself out of the window here isn't them showing you Tommen's
Sacrifice for the throne it's Cersei
Sacrificing Tommen in her pursuit of power when they flashed the card of the othes people swore in the night Kings army
Marches south into Westeros they're mostly referencing the Nights Watch O's to protect the realms of men there's a couple more clips of Jon Snow
Protecting everyone as they race for Daenerys dragons last season and then they flashed the hashtag for the throne so
infinity war style they're giving you a fake Hulk to mislead you about what the true theme of season 8 is going to be
Mostly I think because HBO doesn't want to give anything away before they're ready to like we'll get a trailer with proper footage and it'll
I'm sure be cut in a very misleading way so we'll have to try and figure out how they're trying to misdirect us but just
Remember that this is a really good exam
of how marketing
Campaigns almost have nothing to do with what the actual plot of the thing you're going to see is they do it with movies all
the time
Marvel is now famous for it Game of Thrones Season eight is gonna be one of the biggest things that HBO
Does in a long time so they obviously want to build as much hype as
Possible without giving anything away until they drop that actual trailer which hopefully will come sometime in the next month so
remember there's a progression of
marketing campaigns first you get pictures
Then a couple weeks after that you usually get a teaser or a trailer or something like that usually around this time of the year
Every season they have revealed some kind of teaser so no worries the real
Purpose of this was to get you hyped up and to reveal that
April would be the release date but if you think about it this way True detective
is starting in January it'll air all of its episodes and then there's a rumor right now that big little lies season 2 is gonna
air after that HBO
typically only does their 1-hour dramas
once per week so that means that all the true detective episodes then probably all the big little lies season 2 episodes
Sunday to Sunday then unless they're gonna start doubling up
episodes on Sundays to get through big little lies season 2 faster the earliest Game of Thrones
season 8 could premiere would be the last week in April which would be April 28th they have not released the official
schedule for big little lies season 2 so if we do find that they're gonna double up on episodes to get them out quicker and
Premiere Game of Thrones faster I will totally do a video about it but right now it would just mark your calendar tentatively for April
28th like I said though there was a big winds of winter
Interview that George art Martin did he was actually trying to promote a couple of his other
Series and he has the fire and blood book coming up but
Every time he does a big interview he always talks a little bit about winds of winter so this is actually pretty good he talks
About how the show has made it harder for him to write the book so this is me reading his quote verbatim
He says the show has achieved
such popularity around the world the books have been so popular and so well received that every time I sit down I'm
very conscious that I have to do something great in trying to do something great is a
considerable weight to bear on the other hand once I really get rolling I get into that world and that happened recently with fire and
blood I was going to sleep thinking of Aegon and Jo Harris and waking up think
Them and I couldn't wait to get to the typewriter the rest of the world vanishes and I don't care what I'm having for dinner
Or what movies are on?
or what my email says
or, who's mad at me this week because
Winter winter isn't out all that is gone and I'm just living in the world
I'm writing about so that's him just saying that the show has become so big that
Expectations for winds of winter and dream of spring have gotten so big around the world that is causing him problems
When he's actually sitting down to write but recently there
Was an illustrator doing the cover for one of the international editions of winds of winter that said they finished their cover so they
expect it to be released sometime next year the publishing house probably
Wouldn't commission a whole bunch of art for the book if they didn't think the book was actually gonna start selling within the next year
But the other really cool quote that he had about winds of winter as he said that I've been struggling with it for a few
years
The winds of winter isn't so much a novel as a dozen novels each with a different
protagonist each having a different cast of supporting players and
Antagonists and allies and lovers around them in all of these weaving together in an extremely complex fashion so it's very challenging
The idea that winds of winter has grown almost too
complex for him to finish in a timely fashion
Has been a thing for a long time in the fandom like everybody realized that a long time ago if I do get any more
News about winds of winter are there any more rumors I will totally include it in a video no breweries and I will do fire
And blood videos when that book is released
Congratulations Ryan Watts you're the giveaway winner from my last big video please email me on the about page of my channel so I can
get your contact details
Click here for my Game of Thrones season 8 episode 1 preview video and click here for my history video on the ancient
Stark kings of winter thank you so much for watching everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight